Mi nombre es Lovegrove. Sólo conozco a nueve Lovegroves,
dos de los cuales son mis padres.
Ellos son primos hermanos, y conocen lo que ocurre cuando, ustedes saben --
así que hay un terriblemente extraño, bizarro, lado de mí,
contra el que estoy luchando permanentemente. Entonces, para intentar superarlo hoy,
me he autodisciplinado con una charla de 18 minutos.
He estado aguantando la orina.
Pensé, tal vez, que si me aguantaba lo suficiente,
eso me llevaría a los 18 minutos.
(Risas)
Okey, soy conocido como Capitán Orgánico,
y esa es una postura tanto filosófica como estética.
Pero hoy, de lo que quisiera hablarles es de ese amor por la forma
y de cómo la forma puede tocar el alma y la emoción de la gente.
No hace mucho tiempo, no muchos miles de años atrás,
vivíamos realmente en cuevas,
y no creo que hayamos perdido ese sistema de códigos.
Respondemos muy bien a la forma,
pero estoy interesado en la creación de forma inteligente.
Para nada estoy interesado en "amorfismos"
o en alguna de esa porquería superficial que ven surgir como diseño.
Estos -- este consumismo artificialmente inducido -- pienso que es atroz.
Mi mundo es el mundo de gente como
Amory Lovins, Janine Benyus, James Watson.
Yo estoy en ese mundo, pero trabajo de modo puramente instintivo.
No soy científico, pude haberlo sido, quizás,
pero trabajo en este mundo donde confío en mis instintos.
Así que soy un traductor de la tecnología del siglo XXI
a productos que usamos diariamente y con los que nos relacionamos bella y naturalmente.
Y deberíamos estar desarrollando cosas --
deberíamos estar desarrollando empaques para ideas que promuevan la percepción de la gente
y el respeto por las cosas que extraemos de la tierra,
y convertirlos en productos de uso diario.
Bien, la botella de agua.
Comenzaré con este concepto que llamo DNA.
ADN: Arte, Diseño, Naturaleza. Esas tres cosas son las que condicionan mi mundo.
Aquí está un dibujo de Leonardo da Vinci,
500 años atrás, antes de la fotografía.
Muestra cómo la observación, curiosidad e instinto operan para crear arte sorprendente.
El diseño industrial es la forma de arte del siglo XXI.
Gente como Leonardo -- no ha habido muchos --
tuvo esta curiosidad sorprendentemente instintiva.
Yo trabajo desde una postura similar.
No deseo sonar pretencioso diciendo eso,
pero éste es mi dibujo hecho en un tablero digital hace un par de años --
bien entrado el siglo XXI, 500 años después.
Es mi impresión del agua.
El impresionismo es la forma más valiosa de arte sobre el planeta, tal como sabemos:
100 millones de dólares, fácilmente, por un Monet.
Yo utilizo, ahora, un proceso completamente nuevo.
Hace pocos años, reinventé mi proceso para mantenerme al ritmo de gente como
Greg Lynn, Tom Main, Zaha Hadid, Rem Koolhaas --
toda esta gente que pienso está perseverando y liderando
con fantásticas nuevas ideas de cómo generar forma.
Todo esto es creado digitalmente.
Aquí ven el mecanizado, el labrado de un bloque de acrílico.
Esto es lo que muestro al cliente para decir: "eso es lo que deseo hacer".
En este punto, no sé si es del todo posible.
Es un seductor, pero siento justo en mis huesos que aquello es posible.
Así que vamos. Analizamos las herramientas. Analizamos cómo se produce.
Éstas son las cosas invisibles que nunca observan en sus vidas.
Éste es el ruido de fondo del diseño industrial.
Aquello es como un Anish Kapoor fluyendo a través de un Richard Serra.
A mis ojos, es más valioso que el producto. No tengo uno.
Cuando obtenga algo de dinero, tendré uno fabricado para mí.
Éste es el producto final. Cuando me lo envían, pienso que he fallado.
Se siente cono nada. Tiene que sentirse como nada.
Fue cuando le introduje agua que me di cuenta que le había puesto una piel al agua misma.
Es un icono del agua en sí misma,
y eleva la percepción de la gente sobre el diseño contemporáneo.
Cada botella es diferente, lo que significa que el nivel de agua te ofrecerá una figura diferente.
Es individualismo de masas a partir de un único producto. Se ajusta a la mano.
Se ajusta a las manos artríticas. Se ajusta a las manos de los niños.
Hace el producto fuerte, el teselado.
Es un "millefiori" de ideas.
En el futuro se verán como eso, porque necesitamos alejarnos
de esas clases de polímeros y usar aquellos para equipamiento médico
y cosas más importantes, quizás, en la vida.
Biopolímeros, estas nuevas ideas para materiales,
entrarán en juego probablemente en una década.
Luce tan chévere, ¿no es así?
Pero puedo estar a la altura de eso. No tengo problemas con ello.
Yo diseño para esa condición, biopolímeros. Es el futuro.
Tomé este video en Ciudad del Cabo el año pasado.
Éste es el lado insólito aflorando.
Tengo este especial interés en cosas como ésta que me maravillan.
Yo no sé si, saben, caer de rodillas, llorar.
No sé lo que pienso, salvo que sólo sé que la naturaleza mejora
con cada vez mayor determinación, aquello que alguna vez existió,
y esa rareza es una consecuencia del pensamiento innovador.
Cuando observo estas cosas, se ven bastante normales para mí.
Pero estas cosas evolucionaron durante muchos años, y ahora lo que estamos intentado hacer --
Tengo tres semanas para diseñar un teléfono.
¿Cómo diablos hago un teléfono en tres semanas,
cuando tienes estas cosas que tardaron cientos de millones de años en evolucionar?
¿Cómo condensas eso?
Se trata de volver al instinto.
No estoy hablando de diseñar teléfonos que se vean así,
y no estoy buscando diseñar arquitectura como esa.
Sólo estoy interesado en los patrones naturales de crecimiento,
y las hermosas formas que realmente sólo la naturaleza crea.
Cómo aquello fluye por mí y cómo emerge,
es lo que estoy intentando comprender.
Éste es un escáner a través del antebrazo humano. Luego es expandido por
prototipado rápido para revelar la estructura celular. Tengo estos en mi oficina.
Mi oficina es una mezcla del Museo de Historia Natural y un laboratorio espacial de la NASA.
Es una rareza, una suerte de lugar insólito.
Éste es uno de mis especimenes.
Está hecho -- el hueso está hecho de una mezcla de minerales inorgánicos y polímeros.
Estudié cocina en la escuela durante cuatro años, y en aquella experiencia,
que era llamada ciencia doméstica, fue un truco mío, algo barato,
para intentar obtener la titulación en ciencias.
(Risas)
Realmente, añadí marihuana a todo lo que cociné -- (Risas)
-- y tuve acceso todas las mejores chicas. Fue fabuloso.
Ninguno de los tipos del equipo de rugby podía comprender, pero de cualquier modo --
éste es un merengue. Es otro ejemplo que tengo.
Un merengue está formado exactamente del mismo modo, en mi apreciación, que un hueso.
Está constituido por polisacáridos y proteínas.
Si viertes agua sobre él, se disuelve.
¿Podríamos estar manufacturando a partir de preparados alimenticios en un futuro?
No es mala idea. No sé. Necesito conversar con Janine
y algunas otras personas sobre eso, pero yo instintivamente creo
que ese merengue puede convertirse en algo, un auto -- no sé.
También estoy interesado en patrones de crecimiento:
el desenfrenado modo en que la naturaleza hace crecer las cosas sin que estés restringido, en lo absoluto, a la forma.
Estas formas interrelacionadas, inspiran todo lo que hago
aunque luego termine haciendo algo increiblemente simple.
Éste es un detalle de la silla que he diseñado en magnesio.
Muestra esta interlocución de elementos y la belleza de cierta ingeniería
y pensamiento biológico, expuestas casi como una estructura ósea.
Cualquiera de esos elementos pudieras colgarlo en la pared como alguna suerte de objeto artístico.
Es la primera silla del mundo elaborada en magnesio.
Costó 1.7 millones dólares desarrollarla. Se denomina Go por Bernhart, USA.
Salió en la revista Time en 2001
como el nuevo lenguaje del siglo XXI.
¡Muchacho! Para alguien que creció en un pequeño pueblo de Gales, eso es demasiado.
Muestra cómo haces una forma holística, igual que la industria del auto,
y luego rompes aquello que necesitas.
Ésta es una forma absolutamente bella de trabajar.
Es una manera devota de trabajar.
Hay -- es orgánica y es esencial.
Es un diseño absolutamente libre de grasa, y cuando lo observas,
ves seres humanos. Salud.
Cuando migre a polímeros, puedes variar la elasticidad, la fluidez de la forma.
Ésta es una idea para una silla, en una sola pieza, de polímero con gas inyectado.
Lo que la naturaleza hace es abrir agujeros en la cosas. Libera la forma.
Elimina todo lo superfluo. Eso es lo que hago.
Produzco cosas orgánicas que son esenciales.
Yo no -- y también se ven espectaculares -- pero
no me propongo hacer cosas espectaculares porque creo que es una absoluta vergüenza.
Propongo examinar las formas naturales.
Si tomaste la idea de la tecnología fractal en profundidad, coge una membrana,
achícala constantemente como lo hace la naturaleza:
podría ser un asiento para una silla,
podría ser una suela para un zapato deportivo,
podría ser un carro convirtiéndose en asientos.
¡Guao! Vamos pues. Es ésa la clase de cosas.
Esto es lo que existe en la naturaleza. La observación ahora nos permite
trasladar ese proceso natural al proceso de diseño cada día. Eso es lo que hago.
Esta es una muestra que está actualmente abierta en Tokio.
Se llama Superliquidez. Es mi investigación escultórica.
Es como un Henry Moore del siglo XXI. Cuando ves un Henry Moore,
aún ahora, tu cabello se eriza. Hay algo sorprendentemente espiritual que conecta.
Si hubiese sido un diseñador de autos, ¡Uf!, todos hubiéramos conducido uno.
En sus días, fue el mayor contribuyente en Gran Bretaña.
Ese es el poder del diseño orgánico.
Contribuye inmensamente a nuestro sentido de existencia,
nuestro sentido de las relaciones con las cosas,
nuestra sensualidad y, saben, la suerte de --
incluso la suerte de lado socio-erótico, que es muy importante.
Ésta es mi obra. Éste es todo mi proceso.
De hecho, éstas son vendidas como obras de arte.
Son impresiones muy grandes. Pero así es como llego a aquel objeto.
Irónicamente, ese objeto fue elaborado por el método Killarny,
que es un proceso novísimo aquí para el siglo XXI,
y puedo oír a Greg Lynn riendo hasta perder sus calcetines cuando lo digo.
Les contaré más tarde.
Cuando examino estas imágenes informáticas, veo nuevas cosas.
Estoy auto -- está auto-inspirado. Estructuras de diatomeas, radiolarios,
las cosas que no podíamos ver, pero que ahora podemos hacer.
Nuevamente, están ahuecadas. Virtualmente están construidas con nada.
Están hechas de sílice. ¿Por qué no estructuras para autos como esas?
El coral, todas estas fuerzas naturales eliminan lo que no necesitan
y ofrecen la máxima belleza.
Necesitamos entrar en ese ámbito. Deseo hacer cosas como esa.
Esta es una nueva silla que debería salir al mercado en septiembre.
Es para una compañía llamada Moroso en Italia.
Es una silla de polímero inyectado con gas.
Esos agujeros que ven allí son muy filtradas,
diluidas versiones del extremismo estructural de las diatomeas.
Va con el flujo del polímero y verán --
ya hay una imagen apareciendo que muestra el objeto completo.
Es fabuloso tener compañías en Italia que apoyen esta manera de soñar.
Si ven las sombras que arroja,
de hecho son, probablemente, más importantes que el producto,
pero es el mínimo necesario.
El ahuecado del respaldar te deja respirar.
Se elimina cualquier material que no necesites
y efectivamente, se logra flexibilidad también, así que --
iba a arrancar a bailar a continuación.
Esto es algo del trabajo más reciente que estoy haciendo.
Estoy examinando estructuras de una superficie y cómo fluyen --
cómo se estiran y fluyen. Se basa en tipologías de mobiliario,
pero no es la motivación final. Está hecha en "aluminum" (Brit.),
a diferencia del "aluminium" (Amer.), y está madura.
Está madura en mi mente, y entonces, está madura en términos de
todo el proceso por el que atravieso.
Esto fue dos semanas atrás en CCP, en Coventry, que fabrica partes para Bentley y demás.
Está siendo construido como conversamos,
y estará en exhibición en Phillips, el próximo año en Nueva York.
Tengo una gran muestra con Phillips Auctioneers.
Cuando veo estas animaciones ¡oh, Jesús, estoy abrumado!
Esto es lo que sucede en mi estudio a diario. Camino -- Estoy viajando. Regreso.
Algún tipo lo tiene en una computadora -- hay este mismo: ¡Oh, mi Señor!
Así que intento crear esta energía de invención cada día en mi estudio.
Esta clase de efervescente, totalmente cargada, sensación de sopa de ideas.
Productos de superficie única. El mobiliario es una bueno.
Cómo le sacas patas a una superficie.
Desearía construirlo un día. Y quizás, también querría construirlo
de harina, azúcar, polímero, virutas de madera --
No sé, cabello humano. No sé. Me gustaría que fuera en eso.
No sé. Si apenas tuviese algo de tiempo.
Ése es el lado extraño emergiendo otra vez,
y un montón de compañías no lo entienden.
Hace tres semanas estuve con Sony en Tokio. Dijeron, "Danos el sueño".
"¿Cuál es nuestro sueño? ¿Cómo derrotamos a Apple?"
Les dije, "Bien, no copien a Apple, ténganlo por seguro".
Dije, "Métanse en biopolímeros". Miraron directo a través de mí.
Qué desperdicio. Como sea. (Risas)
No, es cierto. Jódanse. Jódanse. Saben lo que quiero decir.
(Risas)
Lo estoy ofreciendo, no lo están tomando. He tenido esta imagen 20 años.
He tenido esta imagen de una gota de agua por 20 años posando en un semillero.
Esa es una imagen de auto para mí.
Ese es el auto del futuro. Es una gota de agua.
He estado dando lata con esto como no puedo creer.
Los autos están del todo mal.
Voy a mostrarles algo un poco extraño ahora.
Rieron en cada lugar del mundo donde mostré esto.
El único lugar donde no rieron fue Moscú.
Sus autos están elaborados con 30.000 componentes.
¿Cuán ridículo es eso? ¿No podrías hacerlos con 300?
Es una cápsula de carbono-nylon formada al vacío. Todo está holísticamente integrado.
Se abre y cierra como una panera.
No hay motor a combustión. Hay un panel solar atrás.
y hay baterías en las ruedas.
Están empotrados como los Fórmula Uno. Los sueltas de tu pared.
Los conectas. Desconectas, te vas de lo más animado.
Un auto de tres ruedas: lento, femenino, transparente,
así que puedes ver la gente allí dentro. Manejas diferente.
(Risas)
Vean esa cosa. Lo hacen.
Lo hacen y no anestesiados, separados de la vida.
Hay un hueco al frente, y hay una razón para ello.
Es un auto urbano. Conduces un tiempo. Te bajas.
Sigues conduciendo hacia un mástil. Te bajas. Te lo levanta.
Expone el panel solar a la luz,
y en la noche es un farol.
(Aplausos)
Eso es lo que ocurre si te inspiras en el farol primero,
y entonces haces el auto de segundo. Estas burbujas --
Puedo ver estas burbujas con estos envases de hidrógeno,
flotando dispersas por el terreno, conducidas por Al (Gore).
Cuando mostré esto en Sudáfrica,
todos después iban: "Sí, ¡ey! un auto sobre un palo. Me gusta".
¿Pueden imaginarlo? Un auto sobre un palo.
Si lo ubicas cerca de arquitectura contemporánea,
se percibe absolutamente natural para mí.
Y eso es lo que hago con mi mobiliario.
Ya no estoy colocando más mobiliario de Charles Eames en los edificios.
Olvídenlo. Progresamos.
Estoy intentando construir mobiliario que encaje en la arquitectura.
Estoy tratando de construir sistemas de transportación.
Trabajo en aviones para Airbus, por completo --
Hago todo esta clase de cosas intentando forzarlas hacia lo natural,
casa de sueños inspirada por la naturaleza. Voy a finalizar con dos cosas.
Ésta es la estereolitografía de una escalera.
Es un poco una dedicatoria a James, James Watson.
Construí esta cosa para mi estudio.
Me costó 250.000 dólares construir esto.
La mayoría de la gente va y compra un Aston Martin. Yo construí esto.
Esta es la información que viene con ello. Increíblemente compleja.
Tomó cerca de dos años porque estaba buscando un diseño "libre de grasa".
Cosas magras, eficientes. Productos saludables.
Está construido con materiales compuestos. Es un único elemento
que rota alrededor para crear un elemento holístico,
y éste es un pasamanos de fibras de carbono
que está apoyado únicamente en dos lugares.
Los materiales modernos nos permiten hacer cosas modernas.
Esta es una foto en el estudio.
Esto es cómo luce más o menos cada día.
No desearías tener pánico a las alturas bajándola.
Virtualmente, no hay pasamanos. No cumple con normativa alguna.
(Risas)
¿A quién le importa?
Sí, y tiene un pasamanos interno que le da su fuerza. Es una integración holística.
Ése es mi estudio. Es subterráneo.
Está en Notting Hill cerca de toda la porquería --
saben, las prostitutas y todo aquello.
Está cerca del estudio original de David Hockney.
Tiene un sistema de iluminación que varía en el transcurso del día.
Mis muchachos salen a comer. La puerta está abierta. Regresan,
porque habitualmente está lloviendo, y prefieren permanecer adentro.
Éste es mi estudio. Calavera de elefante de la Universidad de Oxford, 1988.
Compré esa el año pasado. Son difíciles de conseguir.
Compraría -- si alguien tiene un esqueleto de ballena que quisiera venderme,
lo colocaré en el estudio.
Así que sólo voy a intersectar -- intercalar un poco
con algunas de las cosas que verán en el video.
Es un video casero; lo hice yo mismo a las tres de la madrugada
sólo para mostrarles cómo es mi mundo real. Nunca ven eso.
Nunca ven arquitectos o diseñadores mostrándoles su mundo real.
Se denomina Plasnet. Es una policarbono --
una nueva silla de bio-policarbonato que estoy haciendo en Italia.
La primera bicicleta de bambú con manubrio plegable.
Todos deberíamos estar montando una de estas.
Así como China compra todos esos autos de porquería,
deberíamos estar montando cosas como esta. Contrabalance.
Como digo: es un cruce entre el Museo de Historia Natural y
un laboratorio de la NASA. Está lleno de prototipos y objetos.
Además, es auto-inspirador. Quiero decir, las raras ocasiones cuando estoy allí,
lo disfruto y tengo montones de niños visitantes --
montones y montones de niños visitantes.
Soy un contaminador para todos aquellos niños de inversionistas banqueros -- masturbanqueros.
Esto -- lo siento -- (Risas)
-- ésa es una semilla solar. Es un concepto para nueva arquitectura.
Esa cosa en el tope es la primera lámpara de jardín a energía solar --
la primera producida. Giles Revell debería estar charlando hoy aquí --
sorprendente fotografía de cosas que no pueden ver.
El primer modelo escultural que hice para aquella cosa en Tokio.
Montones de cosas. Hay una pequeña silla en hoja -- esa cosa de aspecto dorado se llama Hoja.
Está hecha de Kevlar.
Sobre el muro está mi libro llamado "Sobrenatural",
el cual me permite recordar lo que he hecho, porque lo olvido.
Hay un ladrillo aireado que hice en Limoges el año pasado,
en Conceptos para Nuevas Cerámicas en Arquitectura.
[Confuso], trabajando a las tres de la madrugada --
y no pago sobretiempo (horas extras).
El sobretiempo es la pasión del diseño, así que únete al club o no.
No, es cierto. Es cierto. Gente como Tom y Greg --
estamos viajando como ustedes no pueden -- nos encontramos exhaustos. No sé cómo lo hacemos.
La próxima semana estoy en Electrolux en Suecia,
luego estoy en Beijing el viernes. Trabajas que colapsas.
Y cuando veo las fotografías de Ed, pienso,
¿por qué demonios voy a China? Es cierto.
Es cierto. Porque hay un alma en todo este asunto.
Necesitamos tener un nuevo instinto para el siglo XXI.
Necesitamos combinar todas estas cosas.
Si toda la gente que estuvo hablando durante este período
trabajase junta en un auto, sería una dicha, absoluta dicha.
Bueno, hay un nuevo sistema de lámparas "X" que estoy haciendo en Japón.
Hay zapatos Tuareg del Norte de África. Hay una máscara Kifwebe.
Ésas son mis esculturas.
Un molde de cobre para gelatina.
Suena a concurso de preguntas o algo así, ¿no?
Entonces, va a finalizar.
Gracias, James, por tu gran inspiración.
Muchísimas gracias.
(Aplausos)